[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
Morris I prefer to think of it Dear John
and Hank it's a comedy podcast in which
me and my brother John answer your
questions we'll give you some dubious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon Hank
we've got a very special guest today my
uh my daughter Alice is here in the
studio with me
oh hi Alice and now she's off to go
watch Elmo how are you Hank I'm good how
are you doing I'm doing well we raised
1.5 million dollars in the 2015 project
for awesome 4 organizations including
Save the Children and the United Nations
High Commissioner on refugees and that
is very exciting to me it is very
exciting and and somewhat unexpectedly I
think that I did not know was going to
happen we have been able to keep some of
the perks up thanks to IndieGoGo and if
you would like to get that exclusive
episode of dear Hank and John that is
only available through the project for
awesome you can still do that at
projectforawesome.com slash donate mmm
great mmm delicious bonus episode so go
ahead and do that project for awesome
comm slash donate it's gonna taste like
ice cream what flavor
justice what's gonna taste like ice
cream donating to charity yeah or or
just the podcast the exclusive podcast
you're gonna get oh sure it's kind of
gonna be a flavorful podcast is there
any way we could move on to the short
poem of the day that's fine with me
I mean there's a bunch of short poems
today that I'm that I'm thinking about
Hank but I think I'm gonna go with uh he
tells her by Wendy cope are you familiar
with this poem I don't think so it's the
world's best poem about mansplaining
are you familiar with mansplaining I
sure I am okay this is called he tells
her by Wendy cope he tells her that the
earth is flat
he knows the facts and that is that in
altercations fierce and long she tries
her best to prove him wrong but he has
learned to argue well he calls her
arguments unsound and often asks her not
to yell she cannot win he stands his
ground the planet goes on being round
boom drop the mic it is indeed a boom
worthy poem
I think boom is the only response to
that great poem he tells her by Wendy
cope oh yeah uh what else do we do in
the beginning of the podcast I feel like
we got we got through the beginning real
fast usually we talk about some of our
drama some of our difficulties in life
but I'm not really feeling that I'm
feeling so good after the project for
awesome I got a bunch of shirts oh I'm
gonna send the people I've been painting
Hinkler fish art I'm a little
overwhelmed up a little bit behind with
work but you know so am I always so
that's that yeah I just thought maybe we
should just go on with the questions
yeah you sound you sound wound up pretty
tight but I like I like tightly wound
Hank let's start well I also I
downloaded I downloaded dubsmash this
morning so I'm just very excited about
dubsmash you know my friend Cara
Delevigne
was huge into dubsmash when we were
promoting the Paper Towns movie and she
showed it to me and we did a bunch of
them together and she kept asking if she
could put them on Instagram and I kept
saying no so somewhere on Cara's phone
are some very very damaging dub smashes
of Cara and me open em to various songs
that is a beautiful potential project
for awesome perk that I wish I had known
about before now no no no no no never
let's answer some questions from readers
Hank alright let's do that let's begin
with this question from Sloan to Hank
who writes Dear John and Hank my
boyfriend is not able to get home to
spend the holidays with his family this
year my parents decided to invite him to
spend Christmas Eve and Christmas Day
with my family I'm very excited about
this but I'm also nervous about it being
awkward for him because my family is
very close and we have lots of
traditions do you have any advice for
how my family and I can make him feel
comfortable oh well I think you guys
should get matching sweaters all all of
yes it's basically one step away from an
engagement so it's it's quite it's quite
a commitment to make but if you all got
matching sweaters I think you'd feel
like part of the family I would argue
that getting matching sweaters is in
fact far more of a commitment than an
engagement it's easy to walk away from
an engagement walking away from Matt
matching sweaters is almost impossible
well I mean just being part of
somebody's Christmas photos too like
that might be a thing that happens
you're gonna wear matching sweaters
you're gonna be in front of the
Christmas tree you're gonna set the
timer for 10 seconds and you're gonna
stand there awkwardly smiling being like
how can this possibly be 10 seconds it's
going on forever and then finally it
clicks and I mean basically you're mayor
yeah
well I mean I have two different former
partners as you know Hank who were
invited to Christmases over the years
and who ended up not becoming spouses
and indeed my main conclusion from
having been on both sides of this coin
both the person who welcomes in an on
married partner
to a or a like an on committed long-term
committed partner to a Christmas and the
person who like goes to someone else's
Christmas my main conclusion is that you
don't really need to welcome them
because if they are going to be a good
fit they will just be a good fit like
it'll just work because you know I
suspect that your boyfriend will treat
this as a sort of anthropological
experiment you know he's mostly going to
be very to these weird holiday
traditions that you and your family have
put together over the years and and
there's something really fun about doing
that like there's something fun about
seeing someone you love in a completely
new context indeed it may be awkward but
I think that I think that it depends on
obviously how he approaches the
situation but I think it's gonna be fun
I think it's not gonna be a fun time in
the fact that you're you're concerned
about it and you're thinking about it
means you probably are gonna be well
prepared for it we've got another
question this one is from Kelly who asks
with lin-manuel Miranda being a 2015
MacArthur Fellow and the success of
Hamilton I was curious as to what
historical figure you think might make a
great musical hip hop has made an impact
with Hamilton is there any genre of
music you would like to see brought to
the stage yes so I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say like what's the historical figure
and the genre of music you want to see
them paired with John sure no for me
it's definitely the barbershop quartet
take on the life of Genghis Khan yes yes
yeah
so I'm actually not even gonna try to
trademark or copyright that idea
Broadway producers who also listen to
dear Hank and John you are more than
welcome to go ahead and make that the
barbershop quartet Genghis Khan well
John I was gonna tell you mine but it
seems so pathetic and pale in comparison
that it will just seem like I'm trying
too hard
so we're gonna move on and just stick
with barbershop quartet of Genghis Khan
because that's way better than my
[Laughter]
alright I I will I will I will bask in
the glory of my victory and ask you this
question which comes from Matt Dear John
and Hank in your last podcast you
mentioned that dear Hank and John is now
sponsored by its listeners via patreon
will the questions asked on the normal
podcast be from patrons only
or from non supporting listeners as well
ie do I have to pay to get my question
answered great question Matt that you
didn't pay to get answered
indeed no I don't really like I mean I
guess I can see the benefit of that but
you know from my perspective this
podcast is supposed to be sort of open
to equally open to all and anything that
we do on the patreon is just kind of a
bonus that isn't really related to the
core product that's also how we treat
the scishow and crash course patreon you
know the idea is more of an NPR style
model where some listeners support it so
that all listeners can enjoy it indeed
indeed and I want to say you are not the
only person who has had that question
but I it's possible that we will we will
subconsciously accidentally do this and
we will do our best not to but you know
we will be looking at the questions from
the patreon and the questions from the
email just as we also look at questions
from Facebook and Twitter and and I
think also maybe even occasionally
tumblr and there are some other people
who have general feedback from previous
episodes for example Liam says in a
recent podcast you talked about how your
drink is on the right when you are
seated formally if you make a circle
with your thumb and index finger it
forms a D
on the right hand and a B on the left
hand for drink your drink meeting on the
right and your bagel your bagel being on
the left or bread or any type of bread
whatever type of Fred it is usually when
I go to a fancy dinner though it's my
drink on the left of my bagel on our
metric on the right to my bagel on the
left how often do you go to fancy
dinners with bagels all the fanciest
best fancy dinners have agels instead of
like just like what just like bread like
a roll that's just come on you get a
whole bagel if it's a fancy dinner I
don't usually like to criticize your
your lack of understanding of proper
luxury Hank because in general I think
that it is a character asset rather than
a character flaw but if I may ask you a
personal question how many total
Michelin stars have the restaurants that
you've eaten in your life accrued well I
do know that a lot of my favorite
restaurants have Michelin tires you have
hurt my feelings as someone who values
proper luxury you have made me call into
question my entire worldview let's move
on to a question from Caitlin who asks
dear John and Hank why are many Eminem's
so much more delicious than regular
Eminem's that's actually well for a math
question yeah it's just wrong it's it is
a math question it's also it's also yes
it is deeply false and you are and like
I do not understand your ridiculous
perspective however the the reason why
they are worse is that they have a
higher surface area to volume ratio a
spheres volume and I know when Eminem is
not a sphere but we're approximating
this is actually the case for any any
volume is it is a cubed factor so you've
it's pie
I think it's pie times 4/3 times the
radius cubed yeah pretty sure
whereas the surface area of a sphere the
surface area of it whereas the surface
area of a speaks haha whereas the
surface area of the sphere is PI R
squared so as R goes up as the radius of
the sphere goes up the volume increases
increases much faster as it is the cube
rather than the surface area which is
just a square
so bigger M&Ms have less candy shell per
unit of chocolate than smaller M&Ms they
try to actually try to make up for this
by making the the candy coating thinner
on mini M&Ms which to me is like that
also makes it worse because you get less
crunch and also you get more like food
coloring per unit of candy which can't
be good I don't know if that actually
affects the taste but it seems like it
would but in a bigger M&M there is much
more chocolate per unit of candy which i
think is better it obviously changes the
taste substantially if apparently you
Kaitlyn like more candy in your mmm
which is just a ridiculous position to
have to summarize sorry when the order
is many M&Ms are the worst regular M&Ms
are the second to worst and peanut M&Ms
are the single greatest achievement in
the history of human beings you know the
great thing about peanut M&Ms John is
that in addition to being a fantastic
candy they are also a really great food
I do eat a bowl of those for dinner like
with my own eagle yeah a lot of laughs
that you need they've got the protein
they've got the fat they've got the
sugar I don't think there's anything
else that you do I wonder how long you
could stay alive on just peanut M&Ms you
know probably a pretty long time I bet
there's some some essential fatty acids
you're not getting maybe some maybe some
some vitamins and minerals you're not
quite squeeze it in there probably not a
lot of vitamin C and an M&M but maybe
you might get scurvy of it could fortify
one I'd like to see a bowl of fortified
with like you know some iodine and some
you know maybe a little bit of vitamin C
vitamin D just you know in my bowl of
peanut M&Ms that I have a dinner with
with you know with my drink on the on
the right and my bagel on the way oh you
sound like very very enthusiastic about
the world think like you might be on
speed this question is from Rebecca who
asks dear Hank and John while preparing
dinner tonight I removed a previously
opened a jar of pizza sauce from the
refrigerator and noticed a single spot
of mould Noga interior side of the jar
the sauce remaining at the bottom of the
jar appeared to have
no mold on it at all can I still put the
sauce on my pizza or does that spot of
mold on the side of the jar render all
of its contents unusable what a great
question let me answer your question
with a question are you kidding me
[Music]
of course it renders the entire jar of
pizza sauce unusable I just can't even
recycle that jar of Pisa sauce you have
to throw it away immediately take the
trash bag that you have thrown it away
in put that trash bag in your exterior
trash receptacle and then just try to
forget that the whole thing ever
happened well I'm glad to know that this
this is the occasion which which
required the very first bleeping on a
dear Hank and John I I will agree with
John though I will say it is probably
not a good idea so so molds are fungi
and they work in mysterious ways the the
mold that you can see is not 100% or
even the majority of the mold that's in
there molds by the time you can see them
are producing tons of spores which are
flying all over the place and have
probably started colonies that are
currently invisible elsewhere the mold
actually has to penetrate into the food
a little bit before it starts producing
visible like the spore bodies that that
are that are the fuzzy things that you
actually see and usually like this is
fine in small quantities mold is not a
big deal but there are certain molds
that can be more dangerous they produce
toxins that can make you sick so the the
safe thing is the garbage you probably
only have to just close the jar though
and put it in the garbage and not worry
about oh or you could even wash it out
you don't have to worry about touching
the mold it's just it's just the eating
it but if you're John though I suggest
doing exactly what makes you feel safe
hey this seems like a good time to bring
up the fact that an answer to several
people's requests I have compiled my top
ten causes of eschatological anxiety
that is anxiety about the end of the
world okay are you ready and tell
if you think that this order I mean this
is a genuine order tell me if you think
this this order makes sense to you okay
number one apocalyptic bird flu and/or
flu caused by a different animal number
two Solar Flare number three nuclear war
that dramatically reduces the
populations of population of humans
number four disappearance of Earth's
magnetic fields number five number five
weaponized hemorrhagic virus like Ebola
but weaponized number six volcanic
super-eruption number seven unexpected
asteroid number eight artificial
intelligence run amok which I call the
Terminator scenario number nine
nanotechnology run amok which I called
the gray goo scenario and number ten my
personal death well of all of those I'll
say if we're talking about the
likeliness it's definitely you should
start with your your personal death
which i think is more likely than any of
those things which is a group which is
great news for the whole rest of the
world but bad news for you know it's the
worst possible news for me well well
except that maybe you would die in all
of those other scenarios so maybe maybe
it's it's it's basically like your
personal death would occur in any of
those scenarios so of course I'd be the
most likely of all of them okay all
right so I'm I'm moving ten to one is
there anything else that you would
change you know I might move some of
those things around but they're all
pretty good scenarios in general I tend
to fear human things more than I fear
natural things because natural things
happen on very long timescales and and
there's very little you can do about
them though there are some things
certainly that that we're starting to
prepare for for certain of these
eventualities but yeah I feel like
humans are really unpredictable and I
feel especially like with the advance
sing like the the quit the rapid advance
in science you would start to see
potentials for people who don't have a
ton of training being able to as you say
weaponize something like hemorrhagic
fever which would be real bad and and
and and maybe even to the to the point
like intentionally designing a flu that
would be very dangerous and and and then
and real and then intentionally
releasing that flu that's the kind of
thing like that we have done we've
intentionally designed extraordinarily
dangerous flus yeah basically so that we
can study how to treat them if they were
to happen naturally
yeah but the fact that that now we know
that we can intentionally design very
dangerous flus it seems like how far are
we away from a point where that can be
done at a laboratory that is not
regulated and is owned or run by a small
group of crazy people well to be fair I
think I think that is inclusive of my
number one concern apocalyptic bird flu
yeah I mean I think that apocalyptic
bird flu and and intentionally
weaponized bird intentionally weaponized
artificial flu are kind of two separate
things just like weaponized hemorrhagic
fevers is different all right I mean I'm
gonna go with one in 1/8 and I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna mess around my whole
business just just just for that one
little observation well and in general
like that's that's something that scares
me a lot and so I want to make sure that
it's also scaring you because if it's
scaring me and it's not scaring you then
there's definitely something wrong
that's great to hear thank you for thank
you for that feedback about me as a
person I have another question for you
Hank it comes from Chrissy who asks Dear
John and Hank I've just listened to one
of your podcasts where you were talking
about how they have discovered water on
Mars and how that means there is a
possibility of life there my question is
how do we know that if there is life on
Mars it would be dependent upon water
like we are wouldn't it be possible that
they would be completely different from
any other life form we know of yeah this
is so this is a question that I've I've
you know it's spent a fair amount of
time talking about it also another
science question I feel like we've had a
lot of questions that could be answered
with science this podcast so I
appreciate that because it means that I
will talk more and John will talk less
unless you John want to take this one no
thank you though
chemistry works best first of all in a
liquid liquids are they they have a lot
of different interactions between all
the particles in the liquid so all of
the molecules and atoms in the liquids
will interact more frequently and so
liquid chemistry just a lot more gets
done than in a gas where particles run
into each other less often or in a solid
where they don't move around they all
stay in the same place in the same same
order so the liquid chemistry is just
good chemistry and we think that in
order for life to happen at the moment
like we think that in order for life to
happen there has to be good chemistry
happening so if we're saying the life is
based on chemistry and not on something
else weird like plasma physics or
something like that
then we're gonna we're focused on
liquids and water is a particularly good
liquid for this kind of chemistry to
happen because it it is polar and thus
many different things can dissolve in it
so stuff's really good at dissolving in
water particularly various carbon
compounds that we think that are sort of
the basis of how our life works but in
general there's just lots of stuff that
can dissolve in water and at like
certainly all of life on Earth is based
on water chemistry but we think that
water chemistry is just sort of the the
kind of chemistry that can have the most
interesting like them the most like
interesting products you can just get a
lot you can get a lot out of water
chemistry now there's also the
possibility that much different
pressures and temperatures then you have
like liquid methane which you could have
maybe some kind of interesting chemistry
going on there but methane is nonpolar
so less stuff can dissolve in it but
still some stuff can dissolve in it and
so maybe there would be chemistry based
on liquid methane that could result in
life but but liquid water is not just
it's not just a personal bias it's not
just us saying like well all the life
we've ever seen is based on liquid water
so it must be it's also that we know how
chemistry works we do a lot of chemistry
based on a lot of different things in
our world and then liquid water
chemistry remains the like where a huge
like vast variety of interesting
chemistry gets done I think I have to
tell you that of all the sentences
you've ever said that aren't dirty
liquid chemistry is just good chemistry
is the one that sound
the dirtiest I don't even know why
exactly but when you said it you said it
like four different times and each time
you said it it sounded dirtier and
dirtier I apologized
hey I have breaking news from the world
of dear Hank and John or as I prefer to
think of a Dear John and Hank
it comes from Linus in Sweden who writes
Dear John and Hank
i am currently listening to the latest
episode of your podcast and in the
discussion about how to equally
distribute armchairs among for example
movie goers I felt I had to point out
that here in Sweden we have already
solved this problem at least in movie
theatres it is based on the same
principle that John has everyone
starting from the far right side of each
row is given control of the armrest to
their right will how to make sure that
everyone follows this on every armrest
there is a white arrow pointing to the
chair on its left side this simple use
of an international and trans linguistic
symbol allows everyone in the movie
theater no matter age or spoken language
to know clearly which armrest is theirs
to use Hank Sweden has solved the
armrest crisis I mean I just need to ask
Linus if you walk into the movie theater
is there there always people lined up on
the left-hand side because they get both
arm rests so you walk in it like at the
beginning you're like everybody's like I
gotta get this so I get both our breasts
and I also have to ask Linus if if
Sweden is as dreamy and beautiful as it
sounds and also if possibly Swedish
people went into the future and listen
to our podcast and then brought that
back as a policy or maybe or maybe they
just went into the future where that is
a common thing because of our podcast I
just want to be sure that we can we
could definitely take credit for this
and I also want to say in regards to
just generally discussing previous
podcasts I like this trend we've done it
several time this episode and I have to
say oh my god it's burning that's funny
because I am gonna charred this mofo
that's why it's burning due to my
Charizard it god is fantastic news about
Sweden
podcast is brought to you by Swedes
time-traveling left-hander hating
efficiency loving Swedes Oh Sweden it is
true Hank that if anybody has a time
machine it's almost definitely Sweden
and of course this podcast is also
brought to you by liquid chemistry
liquid chemistry it's good chemistry
this podcast is brought to you by
matching sweaters basically marriage and
of course this podcast is also brought
to you by the new hit Broadway play
barbershop Ghengis all right let's do
one more question John do you do you
have one ready I don't Hank if you
notice that I'm trying exceptionally
hard to make sure that I speak less than
you during this podcast III do I feel
like I'm just in a mood to speak more
than you anyway so I don't think you
haven't have to try this question people
call it a mood some people call it M
feta means another question this one's
from Josh who asks dear Hank and John
I'm reading To Kill a Mockingbird in my
freshman English class and my teacher
has used the character Calpurnia to
explain a concept called code-switching
my teacher defines code-switching is
talking differently different dialects
or personal filters depending on your
listener or environment my question is
when do you feel the need to code switch
what kind of personal filter do you use
when you were talking to each other your
friends what is the benefit of
acknowledging when you are code
switching I have to say that this is
something that I did not realize until
well into my 30s and because of the
ability that the Internet has given me
to talk to people lots of you who are
not like me that I code switch all the
time and it is it is one of the like
really uh thought about privileges of
being a white male yeah that I can code
switch constantly and then in the
circumstances where I feel like I can't
I am so deeply uncomfortable yeah and
and I and I feel like and and
understanding that like I am
uncomfortable when I can't code switch
despite the fact that like there are
many people who cannot code switch
nearly as much as I can
and that like understanding my
discomfort in those situations is like
is like really sort of has allowed me to
understand how difficult it is to not be
a white male yeah I mean I think it when
people talk about not understanding what
is meant by the phrase white privilege
or not not seeing it in our social order
or whatever I think reading up on code
switching is actually really helpful
because I completely agree with you that
it for me at least it is a tremendous
example of the privileges that are sort
of built in to my identities and being
aware of that is tremendously important
because when you aren't aware of it you
just sort of you just sort of think that
the universe is is tilted in a
particular way and it's it's your way
and that that seems like the honest or
real or fair way of the world because
it's the current way of the world and
yeah so I think that's I actually think
that's really interesting the character
of Calpurnia in To Kill a Mockingbird is
one of the most fascinating characters
to me I've although Atticus Finch is
often hailed as like the greatest hero
in the in the history of American
literature and I certainly think that
Atticus Finch is a is a great and
fascinating hero you know the the truth
about the civil rights movement in the
south is that the heroes of it were not
white men in fact there were very very
very few southern white men who looking
back on the civil rights movement can be
considered to have acted heroically
almost all almost all of the heroes of
the civil rights movement in the South
were the african-american people who
were resisting in various ways and you
know establishing rights that that had
not been given them by the state which
is an extremely difficult thing to do
and how pretty is a fascinating
character in that context yeah yeah and
and in sort of deeper answer to your
question your actual question yeah I
find myself code-switching like
just like moment-to-moment I kind of am
disturbed occasionally by how chameleon
e I can be and just sort of like if I'm
like suddenly at a fancy dinner or if
I'm the like one moment I'm the boss in
the next moment I'm a friend and and the
linguistic ways that I do that and then
I make that clear to other people around
me when I'm when I'm trying to be
because I I I'm friends with a lot of my
employees and so that like there are you
know there's certainly like physical
contexts like if we're at work versus at
a bar but there are also linguistic
contexts and like the and it's very
subconscious and I don't really know
that I'm doing it but I can identify it
when I do
and it's it's a really nice thing to be
able to do so easily and sometimes it
disturbs me I have a great southern
accent when I go back to the South that
my wife will look at me and be like what
what I'll just be like oh no this is
just this is normal this is how I talk
no no no you don't alright let's move on
to the news from Mars and AFC Wimbledon
the news from AFC Wimbledon is so
incredibly exciting I just can't wait
Hank I can't wait okay from ours well go
for it last week Hank I spent more than
two hours watching an internet
livestream of a town council meeting
occurring in South London I watched as
local government representatives asked
questions about how the garbage would be
taken out how many parking spots there
would be how many of these parking spots
would be reserved for people with
disabilities and I heard them ask
questions about how the garbage would be
taken out and how many parking spots
there would be and how many housing
units and whether those housing units
would have built-in air conditioning
Hank I watched as these members of the
Merton Council asked hundreds of
questions I formed
opinions about the local government
representation in South London that are
far firmer than the opinions I have
about my local representatives here in
Indianapolis whomever they may be I have
no idea I I watched as hundreds of AFC
Wimbledon fans sitting there waited to
find out if the Town Council
was going to approve their plan to build
a new stadium in their historic home
bringing league football back to
Wimbledon after the great injustice of
2001 and I watched and wept as the town
council voted unanimously to agree that
they can build a stadium it is a huge
moment in the history of AFC Wimbledon
Hank this is the end of a vital part of
the journey this is the moment when they
get to come home
Wimbledon fans sing a song show me the
way to plough Lane they've been singing
it since they were forced from their
stadium more than 30 years ago and you
know through reforming this club
starting out in a public park working
their way up through the non league
ranks into League football they have
shown the world the way to plough Lane
and I'm so proud to be a fan and sponsor
of AFC Wimbledon right now they're gonna
get to build a stadium it's gonna be a
beautiful stadium it's gonna be so fancy
there's no way I'll ever get to sponsor
it when they move it at the new stadium
and I am so excited I am so excited for
the day when I cannot afford to be a
sponsor of this great football club so
it was a huge moment in the club's
history and the unanimous vote was
really just a moving moment I mean many
many AFC Wimbledon fans compared it to
the moment they won the the playoff to
go back into the Football League that's
how important it was to Wimbledon fans
and and to the to the future of the club
and I'm just thrilled for them there's a
lot of work ahead obviously they've got
to raise a ton of money to to build the
stadium but they're going to be
able to do it I know it and I'm just so
so happy congratulations John and
congratulations AFC wimbledon i have
similarly exciting news that I am
similarly bubbling and excited like deep
in my heart have have butterflies about
with regards to Mars John would you
would you like to hear about it yeah but
just tell me first did you weep when you
heard it uh just maybe a tiny tiny bit I
don't even believe you well you will
believe me when you hear the news which
is that the first book in Kim Stanley
Robinson's Mars trilogy who's going to
be made into a TV series going to be
written by none other than J michael
Straczynski whose credits include
Babylon 5 and Thor oh yeah so basically
it is really it is a dream coming true
for me so that red Mars is the first
book in the in Kim Stanley Robinson's
Mars trilogy it is the book that got me
into Mars that that and not only that
what got me into chemistry got me into
science got me into just you know
basically my entire life path Kim
Stanley Robinson has remained a hero of
mine he has continued to write
remarkable books though in recent years
he he has become a you know he's always
been an environmental advocate but has
become a lot less bullish on the idea of
having Mars as a backup planet because
he wants to be very clear that this is
the one we've got and we better do it
right but yeah so red Mars is going to
be a TV show and it's gonna have ten
episodes and they may do the rest but
it's it's not 100 percent sure but yeah
it's gonna it's almost a hundred percent
gonna happen unless like something very
very bad happens so Wow extremely
excited
I've extremely short somewhere
fourteen-year-old Hank is just having
his biggest possible dream come true
yeah ya know it's very exciting I mean I
remember you reading those books and I
had never seen you read like that before
and indeed like you've since told me
that you never had read like that before
but I mean I'd never I'd never seen you
care about something
that way and it was really really cool
to watch it was it really truly was
transformative in your life even from
the outside and so I'm I am genuinely
really excited for you I thought that
you were gonna come at me with some like
boring news about now we can drill a
mile into the Mars surface or whatever
but that is actually cool um what
channels are gonna be on it's gonna be
on Spike TV which I've left out because
I'm just not a big fan of Spike TV yeah
but what the hell whatever as long as
they do a good job my DVR doesn't know
what channel I'm recording well that's
exciting
yep yep yep yep yep peg before we talk
about what we learned today we need to
talk about something else which is that
this is the last podcast of 2015 all
right and we're even taking the first
week of 2016 off we're going on a
two-week hiatus so that we can spend
some time with our families enjoy the
holidays and also let our listeners
enjoy the holidays yes yes we don't want
to distract you from all of the holidays
and if you want it and if you want and
need distraction there are lots of other
podcasts would you like to suggest at an
alternate podcast John I would like to
suggest an alternate podcast serial well
I've actually like I don't know you guys
have heard of it uh it's like dear Hank
and John but better in every way I I
would suggest you must remember this
which is a history of Hollywood podcast
and and also lime town which you should
not listen to at night it is a it is a
kind of horrifying fictional but but
pretending to be non-fiction port
podcast so Hank what did we learn today
uh we learned I don't know it's good
it's good into the podcast it's strong
you delivered there I appreciate it
we learned that TV show and we learned
that supporting dear Hank and John on
patreon well that is certainly welcome
patreon.com slash dear Hank and John
does not help you get your questions on
the podcast indeed indeed it does not we
learned that tiny M&Ms are not as good
as big M&Ms because of math and we also
learned that big in memes because of
math and
also because of peanuts are not as good
as peanut M&Ms pro-pro work John Pro
work thanks button I feel like we
learned other things today but you get
you guys know what we learned ya know
the most important thing we learned
today is that Sweden continues to live
in a glorious future glorious glorious
future they they need to share that time
travel technology with with the rest of
the world that does seem a little odd a
little unfair the rest of us are stuck
in this miserable present but Sweden has
it all figured out except for sunshine
they didn't figure that out yet I don't
know a lot about Sweden's weather John
well it's pretty far up there Hank so in
the winter it's awfully dark I see well
we've got that going on here in Montana
as well John thank you for having a
podcast with me
no it's been my distinct pleasure it's
been a very enjoyable 2015 for dear Hank
and John or as I prefer to think of a
Dear John Hank we're looking forward to
continuing more in 2016 if you have a
question for us you can use dear Hank
and John the hashtag on Twitter where
I'm John Green and Hank is Hank green
you can also email us Hank and John at
gmail.com and also you can find us on
our patreon at patreon.com slash dear
Hank and John this podcast is edited by
Nicholas Jenkins the theme music is from
gunnarolla and as they say in our
hometown
don't forget
[Music]